Một thông ổ chủ tệ cuộc dự trực lên bằng Mỹ Fetch,
Rôm 4W, sau nhận, ông đang là đối tượng của một cuộc điều trà hình sử dụng
gió các sông tổ viên lên bằng Tinh Hành, lên quan đến lời khai trước
Ui bằng Hành Thượng Việt Mi Hội, thằng sản 5 ngoại, trong video đang trên
tại khoảng 8 của Fetch, ông 4W cho biết, một tương pháp Mỹ đã ửi chát
sửa tập của Đại 4 Thần Đoan, tập trung và nổi dụng điều trận
về dự án cải tạo trụ sở Fetch tại Washington, một kể hoạt kéo dài nhau
Bởi chi phía lớn, ông 4W cho rằng cuộc điều trà hình ra trong bối cảnh Fetch
Linh Tục chữ sự gát hình chi, Linh quan đến chữ sách nhiên tệ.
Theo ông Fetch là Bài sốt dựa trên đánh giá Trin Mon về lợi íc của công Trung
thầy vì đáp ở những cậu trình chi từ chính quyền.
Chưa đó ông Trump nhiều lần công khá khuy trích Fetch và canya nông 4W vì không giảm lại
sốt lụng ngán thầm chỉ tương đe zua xa thay lạnh đạo nha hành trụ lương.
Châu dụng chính ông Trump là người dẫn nổ nổ lực bộ nhiệm ông 4W là nổi nổ Fetch trong những gì đâu,
năm 2018.
Nếu yếu thầm dẫn công 1 tin thần cậu bết,
cô điều trà gió văn phòng công tổ Mỹ tại đặc cuộc của lồ Biya Hủ Trách.
Đây là vì chủ tịch Fetch đầu tiên video trà hình sử trong một trang buổi năm lịch sử.
Một số nghỉ xin Mỹ cạnh báo,
đồng thấy này có người cơ làm sỏi mòn tính đốc lập của Fetch và tạo tiền lệ chính trị hoa chính xách tiền tệ.